shout out to my guy Kyle Jen Carter Tata
what the world we outside man it's a
[__] movie what we doing welcome
welcome hey how old are you bro I
haven't met you yet you look like a very
young man pause you look like you're
like [__] 12 bro I'm old enough man
so you're like 17 old enough are you old
enough to drive yeah are you old enough
to buy cigarettes
yeah okay so you're 18 is is are you old
enough to buy liquor yeah all
right when I you know what for me we all
how y'all been doing it's been like two
months living a dream last time you guys
here we drank black coffee together that
[__] was dumb nasty I never had that
[__] again I like coffee you like Cofe
never really my thing why not it just
like doesn't look appealing doesn't look
appealing yeah what does look appealing
[__] G this looks a bil that that bendo
Becky boy you have a as tray gang yeah
have you ever seen un hey can I ask you
guys a question how appealing does sexy
Red's [__] look that's a good
question good trying to go it's a new
it's a new yeah like well he said [__]
looks appealing I'm just curious on the
appeal see that I didn't see her I
didn't see that going around I can show
it to you that [__] look that [__] look
regular bro it I didn't think it looked
bad yeah it look like regular [__] I
thought people were being a little tough
on it I'm like guys it looks to me
draging where I D they was dragging it
[__] don't really get [__] in real
life it's little dumb ass white
kids white kids bro what the [__] way to
make it racial right away off the top
away did you see it no you're a
liar he try I seen it what you think it
was solid right wasn't bad right it
wasn't bad honestly better than I
thought yeah I thought it was going to
be Walky by the way they was putting it
I thought that [__] was going to be
walk like bad Walky [__] on I thought it
was going to be some real roast beef
some curtains you know it was
solid all sexy red man she a sweetheart
I [__] with sex she got a solid box box
down there you know I love her energy me
too did you guys like the new Drake
album he got some good songs on there
it's not bad it's different feel me I is
it different it is different different
like how bro like what Dr likes to do he
likes to do the same thing over and over
I no
[__] he what am
i g he don't do that my son he get on
different beats
bro I really lik I really liked when he
did the EDM album cuz at least he tried
something new bro this album was
something new is you really listening
yeah I listen to the whole album mean I
don't think you really listening to it
game I did this sh with him Savage is
the best track I love the song with
jcole that [__] is fire I love the song
with sexy red and
scissor surprised me I ain't going to
lie I jacked that you goinge that in the
clubs what you say you jacked it yeah I
jacked it what's that mean means I [__]
with it some New York L okay I just got
to make sure I'm just letting you know
cuz you know where I'm from if we say we
jack something either stole it or you
know it's like I I I got jacked off you
know oh
right
no so you guys uh you guys have been
going crazy uh since the last time you
were here obviously y'all were going
crazy last time you were here but now
y'all got a song going crazy on the
radio how's it feel like get in the car
and turn turn the [__] on and your
shit's playing does it feel good now
every time I see it I start smiling it's
a Walky
feeling radio yeah what's Walky
mean please put me up on your guyses
yeah like that's a crazy two walk it's
that drip okay so if like y'all are
Walky right now with the drip no walk is
like drink bro no not even bro no I know
walk's like like like actual lean right
like yeah yeah that's Walky and feel me
his son is crazy like wow that's Walky
that's wild that [__] Walky like yeah it
can mean good it can Bean
bad so it's got multiple applications
yeah basically like your sprite's real
Walky or yo you look at dumb Walky right
now yeah you can say somebody look
walkie if but for me it could be good
Walky or bad walkie what about a Jabba
Walky H what do y'all think about that
the [__] is a jaak they're dancers
they're Asians oh the [__] might be
wearing a mask yes yo them [__] nice
where my dad what's a jabu walki bro
what the [__] the real walkies the
the real walkies bro wearing the mask
bro the white mask N I got to see you
know that I don't bro about aren't there
walkies in Star Wars there's walkies in
Star Wars I I ain't watch Star Wars you
guys have never seen Star Wars Star Wars
was for for the weirdos growing up what
the [__] does that mean where the [__]
did y'all watch it Star Wars Star Wars
is for the School shooters bro what Star
Wars is for School
shooters Star Wars is for the scho Jen
are you co-signing the school shooter
Star Wars correlation anime was for the
weirdos too yeah I was never watching I
only watched one anime bro and I should
was that fire I used to watch a little
bit of Dragon Ball Z but that [__] was
like Dragon Ball Z was acceptable yeah
acceptable travies you've never seen
them no you mean mes they dance bro they
dance bro they're like [__] sick ass
dancers they got they got a Vegas show
[__] is nice
bro not Mom they were jacking for
sure what
what hey man I'm just trying to I'm just
trying to you know I'm just trying to
see what they're I'm trying to you know
get down with the Brownsville lingo my
apologies that was bad Jesus I guess I
[__] missed that one by 1,000 miles
you got it so no Star Wars you guys ever
watch Lord of the Rings oh
wow star Boy watch
that Harry Potter Harry Potter I tried
to watch Harry Potter like it I could
have grabbed like you ever watch Percy
Jackson perect oh the um that was kind
like Harry Potter and [__] huh I know
what you talking about I watch that sh
but Harry Potter with the gods right
like all those type of shows for the
serial killers Bro [__] what ter you got
to chill bro I guess I'm a Serial
K nigg
be what's y'all's favorite Disney movie
oh um Let It Sean ksta I don't even know
what that
is it I'm sorry what says the guys who
ain't never seen [__] Star Wars
judging me you want know letter shine
Google that [__] what the [__] is a
letter shine with the rap [__] yes
Roxy I'm
sorry about that yeah I like to oh this
okay what's y''s favorite car hey
Classic this I what is what's y'all's
favorite cartoon Disney movie yeah I
said Toy Story this is a live action is
the guy story definitely Toy Story's
fire Disney pixx Disney
st which one the real one Toy Story was
fire Cinderella was fire Cinderella huh
yeah nice I like cars Princess and the
Frog fr amazing what cars is fireing you
guys ever watch wre
Ralph my favorite movie my favorite
movie that's that
[__] why do you why do you why do you
relate to Ralph cuz he's like he's
misund the what Big Hero 6 on Disney
which one big hero big yeah yeah that
was on Disney solid very underrated
movie watch is t i you guys ever watch
Wall-E Wally was
my that to make me c they Val some fire
and it's so good cuz it's got no it's
really no talking in it it's just like w
it's like the [__] and the [__] robot
and the dude robot you know and they
like you know shout what's the what's
the name Eva EV is it Eve or Eva I
forgot I think it was evil yeah great
movie watch W if we got to go to the
movies today bro y'all horing it's a new
movie dad just came out is there a new
movie I don't know mad new [__] just
came out I just watched uh what's the
last movie I saw I don't even know the
exorcism came out I heard that show was
mad scary yeah you didn't see the OG one
I don't really like scary movies I feel
you you like you guys like scary movies
I do what do you like what what's your
favorite uh insidious insidious that's a
yeah the last Insidious yo the last
Conjuring that they dropped was wild
scary I feel like scary you don't like
scary movies Jen n i don't I wouldn't
watch it on my own I I never watched a
scary movie on my own can you turn your
mic towards your mouth PA yeah never
yeah I don't really watch scary movies
on my own bro we group out in cool I do
scary movies what about saw yo we about
to go watch
yesterday they just dropped a new one
they brought the dude back the dude died
a million [__] times and somehow he's
[__] back again I don't get it it's
[__] crazy you guys while you're out
here you guys need to go to Halloween
Horror Nights at Universal Studios
Halloween Horror Nights yo we were
supposed to go there last
nighto no the [__] was telling me to go
there I was fight BR [__] guys
chasing you around we out y'all be
horsing nigg don't want to listen wait
wait what does that mean if someone's
horsing [__] you just snotted all over
the
mic
[__] that was a that was a lot of
[__]
said I see it it's hanging on the mic
cord I'm holy
yo son just went crazy on with the the
booger just flew yo she look like Anyway
[__] just viral feel me n we a go
viral what's h mean I want to see on the
internet what I hor mean like like like
for me like you like uh mean you horing
bro horing mean like youing like if
you're [__] a [__] are
youing l oh Lolly gagging okay see
you're speaking all Whitey language
you're [__] Lolly gagging bro [__]
Lolly gagging with me you're [__]
Lolly gaging bro [__] [__] n
bro ganger ganger around what is it
ganger I put gangster at the end all my
it's like it's like a period basically
it's like but like it can start a
sentence too gangsta has mad meaning I
mean I'm aware that one I'm pretty
hipped to you know I'm not a [__] I'm
not a total weenie you know I'm saying
like in New York we say yeah I think
they say Gangsta a lot everywhere all
the time but wait we're not calling
somebody gangster we're just saying
gangster is there anything Brownsville
specific y'all say that's only like
people would only know if they're from
your area Brooklyn that's a lot of
[__] n grew
too grew I ain't that's some new [__]
though like what some Spanish [__] that
ass I mean it's really like some
Spanglish [__]
nice